in the opening scene we are introduced
to a woman named Nita Hooke who lives
alone in a small apartment in the north
of England she works as a sales
assistant at a store called posit
specifically in the Footwear section she
spends her day opening up the store
helping out customers and doing
everything she can to be the best
employee in her boss's view however she
is often bullied by her fellow co-worker
Vicki who often makes her cut her lunch
breaks short and deal with difficult
arrogant customers one day she is even
asked to deal with a suspicious man
named Keith hulligan who is rumored to
have killed his wife he also looks like
a big old pedo in the midst of all this
the town is politically charged and a
conservative government is on the rise
most of the population hates the
immigrants and wants them out of the
country it is then shown that the year
is 1979 and a local leader named Michael
smart is trying to gain power Nida also
faces racism and alienation due to her
Indian background the people in the
street give her suspicious side-eyed
glances while Vicky hates the fact that
she eats Indian food nation of these
negative experiences makes Nita Harbor
violent fantasy when she meets arrogant
customers but she never acts on them one
day at work the manager who seems to
have been tipped by Vicky asks Nita to
eat her Indian lunch in the basement in
order to avoid any potential smell Nita
innocently complies and heads to the
basement during her lunch break there
she stumbles upon a collection of old
newspaper clippings detailing various
tragic events among these clippings she
discovers A peculiar stone with an
engraved symbol when she proceeds to
pick up the stone she accidentally cuts
her finger smearing blood on it
regardless she secretly Stuffs the stone
in her pocket before leaving the
basement later back at her home Nita
takes the stone in her hand to her
astonishment she hears a voice coming
from the stone The Voice introduces
itself as a demon named Gap and reveals
that the stone she is holding is a
powerful Talisman The Demon tells her
that by inadvertently marking the
Talisman with her blood Nida has become
bound to a chilling obligation to carry
out three human sacrifices or else the
world will meet its send as expected
Nita doesn't believe all of this but the
next second the demon takes on a
terrifying physical form scaring the
life out of her when she continues
screaming Gap transforms into Nita's
favorite singer from the band Boney M
Nita is unable to believe her own eyes
but Gap goes on to say that they must
execute one person per day in order to
prevent the impending apocalypse
overwhelmed and uncertain Nita initially
considers the entire situation to be a
mere hallucination and tries to ignore
the entity's demands however Gap removes
her doubts by revealing a glimpse of a
world in Ruins with a simple snap of his
fingers driven by Panic Anita storms out
into the Dark Knight and comes across a
39 year old man named Tim Simons who is
walking his dog under a bridge Gap who
follows her everywhere urges her to make
her first sacrifice Juanita hesitates
the demon claims that Tim is a bad
person who prays on his own 12 year old
daughter he even shows her a vision of
that disgusting scenario this is enough
to persuade Nita and filled with rage
she uses a brick to strike Tim on the
head killing him instantly however right
after she commits the deed she returns
home and throws up she is unable to
sleep the whole night as the memory of
what she has done weighs heavily on her
mind at one point she even contemplates
surrendering herself to the police but
Gap stops her warning her that failing
to complete the remaining two sacrifices
will result in the apocalypse the demon
advises her to pretend as if everything
is normal so that she can avoid arousing
suspicion from anyone the next day the
police find Tim's lifeless body beneath
the bridge and start an investigation
meanwhile Nita goes about her usual
routine at work pretending as if nothing
has happened Gap continues to follow her
persistently encouraging her to select
her next victim however Nida ignores him
and heads straight back home after work
when she spends the entire day without
killing anyone Gap warns her that
failure to do so will trigger an
apocalypse and even shows her news of a
potential nuclear war between Russia and
the U.S as evidenced makes Nita realize
that he is speaking the truth so she
selects a weapon of choice which turns
out to be a hammer she then heads to the
local bar for a drink hoping it will
give her some courage at the bar the two
spot key and GAP confirms that the man
indeed killed his wife this means that
Keith is perfect for their next Target
he also still looks like a big old pedo
meanwhile the bartender and a bar maid
notices something amiss about Nita as
she appears to be talking to herself
unaware that she's communicating with
gap a short while later Nita follows
Keith out of the bar and approaches him
who then invites her to his place as
soon as they arrive Nita takes out the
hammer from her bag and gets ready to
kill him but just then a scared Keith
confesses that he is a bad person and
that he feels guilty about everything he
did despite this Revelation Nita with
only six minutes until midnight strikes
Keith in the head repeatedly until he
dies later as she is about to leave the
house Keith's brother Chris enters and
notices Nita with her blood-stained
jacket in an attempt to erase all
evidence Nida ends up getting in a
scuffle with Chris and stabs him fatally
with a kitchen knife Upon returning home
Nita is racked with guilt because this
time she killed an innocent person
nonetheless Gap insists she must move on
from the incident as her assignment of
killing three people is now fulfilled
but surprisingly the Talisman symbol
still indicates that the apocalypse has
not been averted perplexed Gap contacts
is higher authorities to inquire only to
learn that Keith's death does not count
towards the ritual's completion because
they can't kill murderers as part of the
ritual it means that Nida must still
take one more life to fulfill her task
this infuriates Nida and she puts the
blame on Gap also claiming that she
won't carry out any more murders however
the demon admits that he wasn't aware of
all this furthermore he reveals that not
completing the task would make him fail
his initiation and he'd be banished to
Oblivion forever hearing this Nita
empathizes with gap's situation feeling
a connection as an immigrant who
struggles to find a sense of belonging
particularly after her mother's passing
hence she reluctantly agrees to
undertake her final task and together
they seek to determine their last victim
while at work the next day Nita and GAP
plan to Target Vicky who consistently
mistreats her just then Tim's grieving
wife and daughter walk into the store to
buy a pair of funeral shoes while
serving them Nita feels very bad for the
little girl but Gap consoles her saying
that her actions have saved Tim's
daughter from a future of misery later
on as Gap is pushing Nita to choose
between killing Vicky and her boss the
local political leader Michael smart
enters following this the boss calls out
to Vicky as the best employee and asks
her to serve Michael as the two talk
Nida learns that Michael is a racist
individual who absolutely hates
immigrants he promises to remove all of
them from the country once he comes into
Power enraged Nita changes her Target to
Michael and asks Gap to show her his
future as he does Nina learns that
Michael will be creating a complete
destruction of the World by declaring
war in the future Gap pleads with her to
select a different Target claim aiming
that his superiors won't be happy with
the sacrifice of Michael Bonita has
already made up her mind she then leaves
the store taking a red leather jacket
she'd been eyeing for a long time hmm
now she kind of looks like a pedo
herself on the other hand a team of
police officers led by Len Fisher is
investigating the initial murder as they
struggle to solve the first case they
come across the deceased bodies of Keith
and Chris upon investigating further
they learned that Keith was at a local
bar the previous night prompting them to
head towards the site the bartender
tells them that he saw an Indian girl
acting weirdly referring to Nita in
addition the barmaid also discloses that
Nita drank two glasses of alcohol alone
and on top of that she was muttering to
herself later in the evening Len visits
Nita's residence to conduct a formal
inquiry he questions her about Keith and
whether she saw him at the bar the night
before cleverly Nina pretends that she
does not know Keith and has never heard
of that name before with this response
she manages to dismiss the police
officer after Len leaves the house she
goes back to Gap and continues planning
Michael's murder a few hours before
midnight Nita and GAP drive to the town
hall where Michael is giving a speech
and wait for him outside unbeknownst to
them Len who is still suspicious of Nita
follows her to the town hall as Michael
walks out of the hall and starts driving
away Nina pursues him while pursuing
Michael's car she notices Len through
her mirror but she manages to shake him
off her tail when they pass through a
closed Railway Crossing after a little
bit of a car chase Nita hits Michael's
car causing him to lose control and
skidding him off the road before hitting
a tree although injured Michael survives
the accident seeing this Nita retrieves
her Hammer from her car and walks
towards Michael with the intention of
Killing Him however before she can do so
Len arrives at the scene and intervenes
preventing her from carrying out the
gruesome acts after this Nita is
handcuffed and taken into custody at the
police station Nina confesses everything
including the existence of the demon Gap
and the dire consequences she was told
would occur if she didn't fulfill the
killings she explains how she believed
that not carrying out the murders would
trigger a nuclear war causing Global
Devastation however this only makes her
look like she's mentally unstable as the
minutes count down and the clock strikes
midnight an eerie silence envelops the
surroundings for a brief moment suddenly
the air raid sirens outside begin to
blare prompting all the officers to rush
out to investigate to their utter shock
they discover that need his Grim
prediction has come true the world is
under nuclear attack meanwhile Gap
appears before Nita once again now that
they are unable to complete the
sacrifice the demon will be banished
into Eternal Oblivion as a result Gap
offers her to accompany him in Eternal
Oblivion which Nita agrees to after a
while of deliberating in the final scene
gapanita exchanged glances as they walk
away together while the world Burns
behind them subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching